[Music]
32 Santa Fe one female shot in the chest
New Mexico prosecutors have charged Alec
Baldwin with two counts of involuntary
manslaughter
okay Baldwin fatally shot
cinematographer Helena Hutchins
accidentally while rehearsing a scene on
the set of the movie rust in 2021 an
incident the district attorney in Santa
Fe believes is Criminal everybody stops
what they're doing right now
crime scene he pointed the gun at
someone else
trigger and with those actions he failed
to do what he was supposed to do
according to the D.A Baldwin's lawyer
said that the actor had no reason to
think there was a live bullet in the gun
or anywhere on the film set here's a
breakdown of the charges and what they
mean for Baldwin we've done this for two
weeks and we did it the right way every
day
video released by the Santa Fe County
Sheriff's Office showed Baldwin
preparing for a scene with a revolver in
October of 2021
according to affidavits from the
sheriff's office both the film's first
assistant director David halls and the
armorer overseeing weapons Hannah
Gutierrez read handled the gun before it
was given to Baldwin for the rehearsal
so you're all right just relax
Halls gave Baldwin the gun and yelled
cold gun indicating the firearm didn't
have live rounds an affidavit from the
sheriff's office said Baldwin took the
gun and fired it
the biggest remaining mystery in this
shooting is how did that live ammunition
end up on the set Santa Fe area District
Attorney Mary Carmack altwees set an
investigation into the incident hasn't
revealed how the live rounds got there
and that the question likely won't be
answered so the district attorney has
said the question of how the live ammo
ended up on set actually doesn't matter
to her case are these are rounds here
regardless of what the armorer did
regardless of what the prop handlers did
regardless of whether you know what the
movie said itself what culpability it
had the argument then would be look Mr
Baldwin has an independent culpability
um either of those chairs during an
interview with investigators Baldwin
said he didn't know there was a live
round in the gun
because the gun goes off
the post to be a cold gun Baldwin's
lawyer said he relied on the
professionals with whom he worked who
assured him the gun did not have live
rounds just because it's an accident
doesn't mean that it's not criminal
prosecutors have charged Baldwin with
two different counts of involuntary
manslaughter the district attorney said
in a statement posted on January 19th
that for the first charge to be proved
there must be underlying negligence we
use the term often culpable negligence
and we're talking about criminal
negligence which means that
an ordinary prudent adult of average
intelligence could have foreseen the end
result the district attorney said the
second charge requires proof that there
was more than simple negligence involved
in a death and that the charge includes
a firearm enhancement or added mandatory
penalty because a firearm was involved a
defendant cannot be found guilty of both
and of course the defendant can be found
not guilty of either and it's the
district attorney who has to prove the
case Beyond A Reasonable Doubt I suspect
the reason why there are two charges is
it makes it more likely that they can
meet their burden of proof in their own
mind that they can meet their burden of
proof in one of the two according to the
district attorney the first charge is
punishable by up to 18 months in jail
and a five thousand dollar fine while
the firearm enhancement makes the crime
punishable by a mandatory five years in
jail
I'm so are they okay armor Gutierrez
read was also charged with involuntary
manslaughter in the incident her lawyer
said that the court filing showed that
the district attorney misunderstood the
facts and reached their own conclusions
first assistant director Halls has
agreed to plead no contest to the petty
misdemeanor charge of negligent use of a
deadly weapon according to his attorney
every person that handles a gun has a
duty to make sure that if they are going
to handle that gun pointed at someone
and pull the trigger that it is not
going to fire a projectile and kill
someone Baldwin has repeatedly denied
pulling the gun's trigger but has
acknowledged pulling back the gun's
hammer and letting it go so you never
pulled the trigger no no no no no I
would never point a gun anyone and pull
a trigger at them never the trigger had
to have been pulled in order for that
gun to go off the trigger was pulled the
district attorney said she is basing her
assessment on an FBI analysis of the gun
that concluded it could not be made to
fire without a pull of the trigger she
says this is a key piece of evidence to
her case to support the charge of
involuntary manslaughter that's what the
prosecutor will be arguing that you
wouldn't depress the trigger unless you
were absolutely sure her that the gun
was unloaded or unsafe and so if the
trigger required a finger pull you know
some force on it that should have been
one of those Fail-Safe steps that was
met but was not met can you guys step
right over here now that charges have
been filed prosecutors will present
their case before a judge who will rule
whether there is probable cause to move
forward as we know from the attorneys
that are involved they've already made
statements that they'll vigorously fight
the case
foreign